alright [ __ ] my hair I know a housing
over my despair back and welcome to
something different something completely
different than what I usually do on my
channel but I'm a little nervous bad cuz
I know this is gonna get [ __ ] ton of
dislikes but I'm still gonna play this
game I know it's a little sipping but
after I played it there were so many
bros that commented and said hey kids
why don't you play something with a good
story because it was pretty much the
first game i ever played actually had a
good story
I'm not saying horror games usually have
bad stories actually yeah they usually
have not bad interesting stories and my
thing has always been playing horror
games I was missed out in a good story
and usually I don't I don't really care
that much I usually don't even bother
with it and but I do appreciate a good
story so I think a lot of people got me
wrong there and this is supposed to be a
great game apparently you can't play
this game without crying I don't know
what's up with that
but we'll see if we see some good fight
and anyway I'm looking forward to
playing and I'm looking forward to Holly
browse with me on this journey and yeah
let's let's just do it let's begin
that is a fireplace I mean a lighthouse
hey I don't know why I always get those
two mixed up it's like I always get fire
trucks and regular trucks missed time
whenever all right and the game has
really awesome music I don't know if you
noticed but it's pretty nice mix doo doo
doo doo
the graphics are amazing too I like the
graphics personally it's not truly or
anything that it looks pretty I like it
that it's pretty it's nice
wait a second my girl is not old enough
to play dad's type of piano I should
play a little piano you didn't have a
brother
oh I [ __ ] let's go wash up that wasn't
the parents or anything oh they're fine
don't worry kids
thank you talking to myself Rosaline why
why were you lucky Neil well excuse me
for her are you kidding that oh it's a
squirrel I thought it was a teddy bear
coming out of nowhere you ran over into
anyway oh let's told me right there you
run over it and hit a tree that's that's
stolen e look don't worry it's a company
car
well are you kidding me the boss is
going to kill us
hmm well just say was I was saving a
puppy I should do it for sure cuz he
likes or doesn't like puppies
oh it's more of a cat person [ __ ] why
does the world look oh man
yes it's so true fine whatever fur ball
he found this crisis advantage good go
write that on your report later let's
grab the equipment from the car and move
already I want to check on the squirrel
are you okay bro how do you pronounce it
I come out I crash the car I trying to
evade it what more do you want not crash
the car and invade it that's asking too
much sorry squirrel I love you
I love you so much let's get the
equipment and get out of here
got the sucker let's roll let's roll oh
yeah let's go where the arrow points hey
don't forget about the cop I just wanted
to see if you remember what they locked
himself how thoughtful of you
oh look an affair uh-oh I'm controlling
the lady all right aah bird [ __ ] out all
right
it's following us that's a little creepy
who put a boulder here maybe it's
immature probably most cucumbers we
don't have time for this fluff hello
they talk let's try pushing it out of
the way maybe we could find a tree
branch to jack it with weight or we
could just call it a night I blame it on
that
aah abort mission and go home you do
know what that you won't get paid if we
don't go through with it right
hmm I do that yeah I need you to fight
all right let's find a branch obviously
they're not gonna end the game if you
click that so here we go oh ok that was
easy
[ __ ] the [ __ ] out of it all right this
better work freakin love like yeah well
us that III don't even
what happened it's some kind of air ball
and what's their skepticism right we
need to jet come right all right so
these two guys it's a little weird
squirrel what are you doing it's a
little weird story basically their job
is to take a dying man's last wish and
make it come true so they feel complete
about their self I think that's all I
know about the story pretty much so it's
pretty interesting so let's keep going
this is the house I guess not his son ah
I totally interrupted it ma they're here
like at that creeper she's creeping all
night long what is she doin not a blood
bad place to retire on huh it looks
around I could do better
of course each night shifts lovin or
Hatem you know the answer you sniff it
out it's probably gonna be another
all-nighter you know I know and I doubt
it'll have any coughing shut up oven and
the ocean waves will sing lullabies
wallabies not through your blabbering in
a wall and your eyelids what what don't
we forgot the equipment [ __ ] hey I'm
not a [ __ ] hey don't say that I don't
get paid enough for this
that's right that's right you got to
carry heavy stuff and [ __ ] now okay we
made it to act 1 I never told anyone but
I always thought they were like yeah I
thought it were fireplace inside I'm
really confused right now
all right dr. Watson doctor resign I
presume you like mother that's so corny
I'm sorry thanks for coming on such
short notice
that's okay I tend to be bad with
predicting tenses well it's such an
[ __ ] are you the patient's daughter
oh no I'm just too scary taking and
these are my children Sarah and Tommy
that's not exactly a 95 job so Johnny
legislate mare
I suppose this John is our man Johnny
listen if I if it's a kid we're dealing
I don't think we're don't want you want
no no he's just praise to be call that
that totally looks like a troll face
Santa Claus he's a subset right now with
this medical doctor come with me
does it look at your trophies Santa
Claus with beard and the hat all right
come on grab the case and let's go when
we when my back break one day I'll show
you where the insurance claim
Hellyeah received equipment all right
let's head upstairs before I dropped it
all right so I'm always controlling her
go up sir
yes I don't see why not okay now that's
gone when I get stuff artists terrifies
get the play the melody Wow
really they fight over who gets to play
the piano that is kids these days nuts
how do you push me did not whatever
you're good morning till nuts anyway
it's beautiful skin is beautiful you
can't do that scheme is not Hara pit I'm
sorry I'm sorry it's not an infinite
amount of horror games out there I
wanted I want to play this I'm sorry
spirit fingers got 11 okay
these kids are pretty good for their age
hi you're the one who said where was no
time to weigh and incidentally I'm the
one who's carrying the whoa wrong boy
[ __ ] it yeah yeah come on along I gave
her like the manliest voice ever ah
there he is
what's she doing all right let's talk to
her ready to set up uh I guess yeah it's
all just a moment what's going on this
is you and me and routing screen uh are
you sure a common household power outlet
is sufficient
now worries we're the experts of course
this is not gonna work oh crap standard
procedures just keeping you on your toes
I make sense
how's she doing not so well if I were to
say you just got a day or two left as
plenty of time so you too can grow into
many wish huh see what I told you to try
it to try at least
but we already succeeded because we're
awesome so what's the wish the mode what
the Mon the mode he wants to go to the
moon a geezer is just keeps getting
crazy huh so can you do it it depends
she meant to say yes freakin love dr.
Watts why don't you tell us about your
client here that I don't really know
much what John is an odd man through the
two years that I worked a reread II
spoke he worked as a craftman for Moses
life and his wife passed away two years
ago
I don't really know buy any details I
would know more every word paperwork for
pete's sake
shush just do your thing well I suppose
if you look around the house you may
find Samantha I suppose Johnny wouldn't
mind and see sign for you - hmm Soviet
alright which one of us plays that all
right cut sharply doctor what's for sure
he's awesome I'll dad I once played
Sherlock Holmes in the high school oh
man he's so awesome I remember you
playing Watson whatever that's me
alright alright just configure this
I gotta start it anyway alright let's go
and looks for clips I guess my shilling
I'm sure you're wrong they're probably
downstairs at the piano all right let's
go down to funk it down mmm dude
white come back here for a moment
I have something for you alright
going back light it daddy let it at all
hey take this okay I'll keep you updated
on Johnny status I hope there's no
self-destruct button I seem to have a
knack of that yeah I got that too
we're so similar you and I watts but
your name summer here I guess I'll check
downstairs first I don't want to play
around too much it's beautiful
all right you kids watch your mom show
me around the house yeah your mom told
me to show me around a house okay maybe
we will maybe I think we just need a
little kind of matching match all what
do you think Tommy that was terrible
all right let's talk why do you punk
once we want a trillion dollars or the
candy cane mom hides from us now of it
uh what that is a giant candy cane on
top of the hive Jeff we can't reach it's
in the kitchen mom put it there to save
for when we do course choice
I get it photos and we can throw what do
you say well uh I don't really feel like
doing that cut the crap and help
plotting - it's - candy is a serious
crime you know I heard you can get six
years for that long ha ha
what does is stupid chintz so stupid
we're sorry we didn't know uh uh well if
you show me around this place now I'll
keep my mouth shut
really you do that first sure I'm
feeling nice today
Wow wait fetch yeah what up I wonder if
my choices will affect the ending I
actually don't know about that I don't
think so actually all right where do we
start
I know there's this funny room in the
basement I don't like that funny room
and what kind of funny room
you see it's weird boy we need to get
the kid stop doing man hid inside a book
in his study uh where the [ __ ] is this
study
maybe here
ah okay this is dubbed book room the
keys
funny room itches dickish book in
aperture the thickest book uh uh uh the
tale of a girl who fell in love with the
zombie who made at the smell of daisies
when the showered
this is Twilight uh read it uh maybe
next time
oh I got it all right the man sure know
yeah cuz no one [ __ ] touches Twilight
that makes sense
that's an excellent way to hide things
all right we can open the funny Bell
millimeter now all right let's go let's
go this is a basement we better take a
turn on the lines before your trip a
hoarder fun behind all right I'm doing
it I did it
sup girl alright going over here girl
what is this a bag of balls gotta love
that a chest it's locked
well we got a bag of balls let's punch
them there you go balls
there you go boss you're welcome boss
there's something up here I want that
anymore books about that and we have
another bedroom team yay
genius pretty bad place to the moon it's
like a cave in here whoo that's actually
kinda creepy while I a Darwin what I
what is that
that's Psyduck a stuffed platypus what
hideous a little Christian spoke it what
what let's take it I guess I guess I
took like a clue or some [ __ ] like I
broken music box and a rabbit folding he
likes to fold those rabbits I guess
that's weird
all right I got one day did you see it
why are you kids know about all those
rabbit okay the old men didn't want
anyone to go inside so we never told him
there there's more of them actually
we're inside your bed and lighthouse
it's just beneath this cliff but I see I
got the keys let me guess you aren't
supposed to go in there either
hey what kids are so annoying
remind me to never keep any locked
cabinets around Yuto so you want to go
to the loo - well it's rather windy
outside but decision I think we'll go
see the lighthouse actually a heck with
that I'm dr. Watts Marion can't stop me
dr. Pierce
come on let's kick some butts you kick
some butt while going outside and wind
alright let's go that's a Scott let's go
to the abandoned lighthouse but in the
next episode
alright oh you see his monitor there I
guess got time on your
anyway I hope your brother's looking
forward to see more of this I'm
definitely looking forward to playing
more like a favorite if you enjoyed it
helps out so much especially when I'm
doing new stuff and subscribe to come
birthday and I'll see you next episode
on wherever I'm a sailor somewhere
inside up again alright we get the
briefcase it has a bomb and we explode
[ __ ]
alright [ __ ] and we get the nuclear bomb
and the snake yes of course yeah
this game makes too much [ __ ] sense
alright uh let's go inside because it's
cold
yes oh that's nice